looks stunning oh thank you you really
do you look gorgeous a beautiful dress
this old thing
stop doing that
we're going to have a good time tonight
thanks for being here yep no
no no yelp is not the correct response
thanks for being here yep uh aubry we're
a big fan
one tiny pee from my dress oh a little
bead came off
look at that yep rip another one off for
andy i think it's the least you can do
oh hi thank you
it's white chocolate fantastic
good thing it's air-conditioned um the
uh
putting that in my pocket i'm gonna say
that later i'm gonna be like why is
there a baby tooth in my pocket
you're a weird man my mother has all my
baby teeth in her underwear drawer
what seriously yeah she has she kept all
your baby teeth and
and she's put them in her underwear
drawer yeah she never told me that but i
found them there once
so now i know
so you know you know that's a shocking
discovery
just now well first of all what were you
doing going into your mom's underwear uh
that's what this is an honor oh oh i'm
sorry this is not part of the interview
suddenly
suddenly i've gone off limits no comment
on that all right well we'll move it
along then
uh all going your way we're going to
talk about the movie in just a minute
okay
um but i want to talk about your
character april and parks and recreation
you've been i think it'd be fun to play
kind of a mean character i think that'd
be kind of a nice thing to do
yes it's very fun it'd be fun to do but
what's what happens when you encounter
fans do fans expect you to be mean some
of them do
i find um yeah some of them a lot of
people
that recognize me kind of back away they
don't
come towards me they don't approach they
recoil yeah i think because i play i
play characters that are mean
um i was in new orleans recently and a
couple
i was standing somewhere on the street
and a couple
like came up from behind me and they
were like you're her you're her say
something mean
and i went leave me alone
and then they started laughing yeah and
they didn't go away
and they didn't go away because you're
giving them what they want yeah and they
just kept laughing they were like do it
again and i was like
leave me the [ __ ] alone
and they're like and they and
they loved it yeah yeah and one time a
little a child's
little girl came up to me in an airport
and just started crying
because she recognized you from the show
yeah but i don't know why i don't know
why she was crying she
walked up to me and i was in line and
she said
excuse me are you april blood gabe from
parks and recreation i went yes and then
she was like
and then she started crying and then i
just started i gave her my hat
and i like just started giving her
things i know it was confusing
you just wanted to make her happy in
that moment so you gave her your hat and
then her dad came and
whisked her away yeah that looked weird
a stranger's like giving her a hat
yeah really strange um i don't like that
at all
i want to make sure well you know you're
in real life i'll i will attest you're
very nice person i
am thank you very much
that's what i'm here to do i like your
southern accent